Andrea was working at her first temp job at Bank of America in San Francisco, learning how to use the computers. And she made this chart with Microsoft Excel. It's very professional-looking. The line that goes across the bottom of the chart lists the years between 1987 and 1997. The left side of this chart, what you might call the y-axis lists numbers of people, going from 0 to 7. There's a legend, and the title at the top of the chart, "My Love Life: A 10-Year Span."
安德里亚在旧金山美国银行做第一份临时工作时，正在学习如何使用电脑。她用微软Excel做了一张图表，看起来非常专业。图表底部的横轴列出了1987年到1997年间的年份。图表的左侧，也就是所谓的纵轴，列出了人数，从0到7不等。图表上方有一个图例和标题：“我的爱情生活：十年跨度”。
It's basically all the people Andrea made out with or slept with over 10 years. And once you laid it out this way, in numbers, it's hard not to start thinking about your stats. Like the huge jump she made in 1994 three to seven.
这基本上是安德里亚十年间接吻或发生过性关系的每一个人的统计。一旦你用数字把这些列出来，就很难不去思考自己的统计数据了。比如她在1994年取得的巨大飞跃，从三个人增加到了七个人。
So seven was my first jump. That was definitely my highest year, but then '95 followed up with a four, which was higher than all the previous year. So I thought at that time that I'd broken a barrier and that it was just going to be smooth from here on out. And then '96, I hit another high with five. So '97 is unexplainable in terms of trends of the chart.
所以七是我的第一次飞跃。那绝对是我人数最多的一年，但紧接着95年是四个，这也比之前的所有年份都要高。所以我当时以为我突破了一个障碍，从那以后一切都会很顺利。然后96年，我又达到了五个的新高。所以97年就图表的趋势而言是无法解释的。
In '97, her number is 0.
在97年，她的数字是0。
I think what explains it is I spent the first six months living at home with my mom.
我想能解释的原因是，那年的前六个月我住在家里，跟我妈妈住在一起。
Then there are the dramatic increases in 1994 and 1996-- very big jumps. Andrea's phrase for what happened in those years? Her slutty years abroad.
然后是1994年和1996年的剧烈增长——非常大的跳跃。安德里亚对那些年发生的事情的描述？她在国外的放荡岁月。
Well, definitely leaving the country brings my numbers up immediately. Me and David Hasselhoff do better in Europe.
嗯，离开这个国家确实让我的数字立即上升了。我和大卫·哈塞尔霍夫在欧洲的表现更好。
So it all started as this funny thing to just try on the computer, kill time with, but as Andrea looked at the chart, it was actually kind of reassuring. First of all, it made her look like such a player, which she wasn't really feeling at the time.
所以这一切最初只是为了在电脑上尝试一下、消磨时间的有趣事情，但当安德里亚看着这张图表时，它实际上让人感到某种安慰。首先，这让她看起来像个情场高手，而她当时并不觉得自己是这样。
And the second thing was that, when you reduce people to just numbers, everything that was painful about your relationships with them-- it just vanishes. The person you kissed who never called you again. The really embarrassing person you'd rather just forget ever happened. It's all gone. The trauma's gone.
第二点是，当你把人简化为数字时，你与他们关系中所有痛苦的事情——就都消失了。那个吻过你之后再也没打过电话给你的人。那个你宁愿忘记发生过、非常尴尬的人。全都不见了。创伤消失了。
It is just numbers. Looking at it this way, the people totally go away. I can't look at a year and think, oh, that was that person, or whatever. Because so many of these things on their own, I would normally classify as failures. They were rejections or something painful. But when I look at it in the context of all this, now these are all my scores. These are my successes. So it's a way to turn things around, I guess.
那只是数字。用这种方式来看，这些人就完全消失了。我无法看某一年然后想，哦，那是那个人，或者别的什么。因为其中许多事情单独来看，我通常会把它们归类为失败。它们是拒绝或是其他痛苦的事情。但当我从这一切的背景来看时，现在这些都是我的得分。这些是我的成功。所以我想，这是一种扭转局面的方式。
This is the thing about numbers. They're easier to deal with than feelings, than the thousand ambiguous and difficult things that happen in life, real life. And so today on our program, we bring you stories of people who have tried to take reality, take emotional situations, take things that never should be expressed in numbers, and render them in numbers. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it is This American Life . I'm Ira Glass.
这就是数字的问题所在。它们比情感、比生活中发生的那一千件模糊而困难的事情更容易处理，真实的生活。所以今天在我们的节目中，我们为大家带来一些人的故事，他们试图抓住现实，抓住情感状况，抓住那些永远不应该用数字表达的事物，并将它们转化为数字。来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
On today's program, Act One, the story of one couple who decided to put a corporate annual report about their own relationship. Act Two, Paint by Numbers, two artists who decided what to paint by hiring a polling firm to ask people what they wanted to see in art. Act Three, When Days are Numbered. Jerry Davidson of Worcester, Massachusetts has been keeping a list of everything he has done since 1955. What does not make it onto the list turns out to be a lot bigger than what does. Act Four, The Salesman. A Husband tries to market himself to his own wife using all the tools of corporate brand marketing. Act Five, Break It Down, calculating the cost of love. Stay with us.
在今天的节目中，第一幕，一对决定为他们自己的关系写一份企业年度报告的夫妇的故事。第二幕，按数字绘画，两位艺术家通过聘请民意调查公司询问人们想要在艺术中看到什么来决定画什么。第三幕，当日子屈指可数时。马萨诸塞州伍斯特市的杰瑞·戴维森从1955年开始就一直在记录他做过的每一件事。事实证明，没能进入这个清单的事情比进入了清单的事情要多得多。第四幕，推销员。一位丈夫试图利用企业品牌营销的所有工具向他自己的妻子推销自己。第五幕，拆解，计算爱的成本。请继续收听。
Act One.
第一幕。
It was called "Bi-Annual Report on Status of Relationship with Significant Other."
它被称为“关于与另一半关系状况的半年报告”。
And so why would any couple choose to analyze their relationship using the tools and graphs and methods of a corporate annual report?
那么，为什么任何一对夫妇会选择使用企业年度报告的工具、图表和方法来分析他们的关系呢？
I think because it seemed the most emotionless. I mean, it seemed the most opposite of a relationship.
我想是因为它看起来最没有感情色彩。我是说，它看起来与关系最相反。
So once a week, for half a year, Travers Scott and his boyfriend, David Eckard, sat down and separately filled out questionnaires to measure the status of their relationship. They tried to be as scientific as possible. They had six categories of evaluation: efficiency, feedback, profitability-- which is what they each got out of the relationship-- security, mergers-- which was their jargony word for their sex life-- and loyalty, which in their case meant brand loyalty to the relationship.
所以，在半年的时间里，特拉弗斯·斯科特和他的男友大卫·埃卡德每周坐下来一次，分别填写调查问卷来衡量他们关系的状况。他们尽可能地做到科学。他们有六个评估类别：效率、反馈、盈利能力——也就是他们每个人从这段关系中得到了什么——安全性、合并——这是他们对性生活的术语——以及忠诚度，在他们的情况下意味着对关系的品牌忠诚度。
Yeah, how hemmed in you felt by the relationship. Did you fantasize about being single? Did you have sex outside the relationship? Things like that. Most of the structural things you see applied to relationships are very touchy-feely, escape from intimacy, co-dependency, psychobabble kind of stuff. And I wanted to use something that didn't have that quite Montessori warm, fuzzy, huggy feel to it, but something that was very cold and removed. And so I wanted to take that a step further in applying it to people, and apply it to a relationship, apply something that cold to love and see what would happen.
是的，这段关系让你感到多么受束缚。你有没有幻想过单身？你有过婚外性行为吗？诸如此类的事情。你看到的大多数应用于关系的结构都是非常感性的，逃避亲密、相互依赖、心理学废话之类的东西。而我想用一种不那么蒙台梭利式温暖、模糊、拥抱的感觉，而是非常冷漠和疏远的东西。所以我希望在应用到人身上时更进一步，把它应用到一段关系上，把那种冰冷的东西应用到爱上，看看会发生什么。
And does that work?
那管用吗？
Oh, no, it's completely futile. It doesn't work at all. I mean, in all these pieces, we were always trying to apply the most antithetical structures of scientific, masculine, scientific method, hyper-analytical, to the most irrational, chaotic, emotional things in our lives.
哦，不，这完全是徒劳的。一点也不管用。我是说，在所有这些作品中，我们总是试图将最对立的科学、男性化、科学方法、过度分析的结构应用于我们生活中最不理性、最混乱、最情绪化的事情上。
And you're saying it doesn't work? Why? What falls apart? What do you lose?
你说它不管用？为什么？什么崩溃了？你失去了什么？
Because it's chaos. It has benefits, but you have to fudge the science a lot. You're trying to quantify things that are really hard to quantify. Like one thing that happened was when we were separated, and we were rating the sexual area, some weeks I would give us a really, really high rating because I was thinking about Dave a lot sexually, and I was having all these warm, fuzzy thoughts and everything. So I gave it a really high rating. Dave gave it a complete zero because we were separated and we weren't having sex, therefore it was a zero.
因为它是混乱的。它有好处，但你必须在科学上做很多修补。你试图量化那些真正难以量化的东西。比如发生的一件事是，当我们分开时，我们在评定性爱领域，有些周我会给我们一个非常、非常高的评价，因为我当时在性方面想了很多戴夫，我有很多温暖、模糊的想法和一切。所以我给了一个很高的评价。戴夫给了一个完全的零，因为我们分开了，没有性生活，因此它是零。
But it does get you into that problem of, how do you even quantify how much love is occurring between people?
但这确实让你陷入了那个问题，你甚至如何量化人与人之间正在发生的爱有多少？
Yeah. I mean, it was easy with things like the phrase "I love you." I could easily count how many times that happened. But trying to determine exactly what was a non-verbal expression of love. Like, I would count gifts, things like that, but do you count an affectionate look? Do you count a punch in the shoulder?
是的。我是说，像“我爱你”这句话这样的事情很容易。我可以很容易地数出那发生了多少次。但试图确切地确定什么是爱的非语言表达。比如，我会计算礼物之类的东西，但你会计算一个深情的眼神吗？你会计算肩膀上的一拳吗？
And how would you count something like, OK, you're at dinner and he reaches over and just puts his hand on your hand as you talk and then takes it away a moment later?
那你怎么计算像这样的一件事，好吧，你在吃晚餐，当你在说话时他伸手过来放在你的手上，然后片刻之后又拿走？
That would be a debatable non-verbal expression. But then, that gets really hard, because if you count every instance of physical expression, is that every single time someone touches you? How do you determine between, is he squeezing your hand because he loves you so much or is he squeezing your hand because you're saying something really stupid and embarrassing?
那将是一个有争议的非语言表达。但随后，这变得非常困难，因为如果你计算每一个身体表达的实例，那是指某人触摸你的每一次吗？你如何判断，他是因为太爱你而捏你的手，还是因为你说了一些非常愚蠢和尴尬的话而捏你的手？
So while you were doing this particular project, did you feel that things just got extremely self-conscious in a way that wasn't perhaps the most desirable outcome?
那么当你进行这个特定项目时，你是否觉得事情变得极其自我意识，以至于可能不是最理想的结果？
It did at first. In the first few months especially, it was very self-conscious. And I knew Dave was keeping track himself of how many times he was saying "I love you," and things like that. But after a while, you just forget about it and it just becomes a habit. Just every day, OK, how many times did this happen, how many times did that happen? I had a little notebook stuck in my jacket pocket that I'd whip out like a irritating reporter or something. "You said I love you," and I'd be scribbling it down. And people would kind of glare at me. It made me look really, really insecure, I think.
起初确实如此。特别是在最初的几个月里，它非常让人自我意识。而且我知道戴夫自己也在追踪他说“我爱你”的次数之类的事情。但过了一会儿，你就忘了它，它就变成了一种习惯。每天都是，好吧，这发生了多少次，那发生了多少次？我外套口袋里塞着一个小笔记本，我会像个烦人的记者一样把它拿出来。“你说我爱你了，”然后我会把它记下来。人们会有点瞪着我。我认为这让我看起来真的、非常不安全。
Yeah, I mean, I've got to say, if I were involved with somebody and I knew that they were counting how many times I said "I love you," I would feel constrained to keep my average up. Do you think people are unconsciously counting anyway?
是的，我是说，我必须说，如果我与某人交往，而且我知道他们在数我说“我爱你”的次数，我会感到被迫保持我的平均水平。你认为人们无论如何都在下意识地数数吗？
Oh, yeah, I think so. Especially, in a relationship, I think the longer it goes on, you have that little-- begrudging everything from, I'm always the one that makes the coffee in the morning, to changing the toilet paper roll to, you never spontaneously-- you don't bring me flowers anymore. I think there's always a tally going on in the back the head, and it helps to let it out, even if it's completely irrational and petty.
哦，是的，我想是的。特别是在一段关系中，我认为持续的时间越长，你就会有那种小小的——对一切抱怨，从我总是早上做咖啡的那个人，到换卫生纸卷，到你从来不会自发地——你不再给我带花了。我想脑后总是在进行核算，而把它释放出来是有帮助的，即使它完全是非理性的和琐碎的。
[MUSIC -- "YOU DON'T BRING ME FLOWERS" BY BARBRA STREISAND AND NEIL DIAMOND]
[音乐 -- 巴布拉·史翠珊和尼尔·戴蒙演唱的《你不再给我带花》]
Travers Scott. His latest novel is called One of These Things is Not Like The Other.
特拉弗斯·斯科特。他的最新小说名为《这些东西其中之一与众不同》。
Act Two, Paint by Numbers. In today's program, we're looking stories of people using numbers in ways that they just should not, which brings us to Alex Melamid, who's using numbers to make art.
第二幕，按数字绘画。在今天的节目中，我们正在观察人们以他们不应该使用的方式使用数字的故事，这把我们带到了亚历克斯·梅拉米德那里，他正在使用数字来创作艺术。
You need to believe, you know? And we were raised, or our culture is we tend to believe in numbers. Numbers are innocent. They're not involved. They're not engaged. They don't cheat on us. They're not politicized, let's say. They're just pure, beautiful, and truthful.
你需要相信，你知道吗？我们是被抚养长大的，或者我们的文化是我们倾向于相信数字。数字是无辜的。它们不参与。它们不投入。它们不会欺骗我们。它们没有被政治化，我们这样说吧。它们只是纯粹、美丽且真实的。
And so, with that premise, Alex Melamid and his artistic collaborator, Vitaly Komar, commissioned a professional market research firm to survey the public about what they wanted to see in art. And then they took the data and they used it to paint what the greatest number of people asked for. The resulting artwork is a landscape, a  hill on the left, a tree on the right, a big lake, blue sky, some deer, a family-- the stats said that audiences wanted to see groups of people in a painting-- and George Washington.
因此，基于这个前提，亚历克斯·梅拉米德和他的艺术合作者维塔利·科马尔委托一家专业的市场研究公司调查公众关于他们想在艺术中看到什么。然后他们获取数据，并利用这些数据来绘制最多数人要求的东西。由此产生的艺术品是一幅风景画，左边有一座山，右边有一棵树，一个大湖，蓝天，几只鹿，一个家庭——统计数据说观众想在画中看到人群——以及乔治·华盛顿。
Because they wanted some political figures. And that was at our discretion, so we decided that who was a better political figure than George Washington for this country?
因为他们想要一些政治人物。那是我们酌情决定的，所以我们决定谁比乔治·华盛顿更适合作为这个国家的政治人物？
Melamid and Komar did the surveys in 14 countries and made paintings for each one.
梅拉米德和科马尔在14个国家进行了调查，并为每个国家创作了画作。
First of all, we found out that people like a landscape, and blue is the favorite color of the people.
首先，我们发现人们喜欢风景，蓝色是人们最喜欢的颜色。
Yeah, I have the statistics in front of me. It says 88% of Americans favor outdoor scenes. 44% prefer blue in their paintings.
是的，我面前有统计数据。它说88%的美国人喜欢户外场景。44%的人在他们的画作中更喜欢蓝色。
Right. And they like wild animals. They like mountains and water. And this came as a shock. We thought, oh, my god, stupid Americans, what do they want, but then having this poll made in different countries, all the countries, with only one exception, wanted the same, a blue landscape.
对。他们喜欢野生动物。他们喜欢山和水。这让人感到震惊。我们想，哦，天哪，愚蠢的美国人，他们想要什么，但后来在不同国家，所有国家进行了这次民意调查，只有一个例外，他们想要的都一样，一个蓝色的风景。
What was the country that didn't want the same?
那个不想要同样东西的国家是哪个？
It was one country, which was Holland, the Netherlands. And they preferred abstract art to traditional art.
有一个国家，那就是荷兰，尼德兰。他们更喜欢抽象艺术而不是传统艺术。
What do you make of that?
你对此有何看法？
Oh, my god, I wish I'm a philosopher, so I can make something out of that. But they live in a very beautiful country, and a museum with full of realists and nice and beautiful art. Maybe they're tired of it.
哦，天哪，我希望我是一位哲学家，这样我就可以从中得出一些东西。但他们住在一个非常美丽的国家，博物馆里充满了现实主义者和美好而美丽的艺术。也许他们厌倦了它。
They don't need beautiful painting.
他们不需要美丽的画。
Or conduction of blue landscapes. That may be the explanation.
或者对蓝色风景的传导。这可能是解释。
When you create works of art from polling even when they create movie endings from polling and other things like that, and create ideas for TV shows by polling people, we get a lot of art in various forms that comes from a perception of a market, a perception of what people will buy. I wonder if it's one of these things where-- creating art this way from polling, you can get competent art, but you're not going to get anything that's really inspiring, anything that really grabs your heart.
当你通过民意调查创作艺术品时，甚至当他们通过民意调查创造电影结局和其他类似的东西时，并通过民意调查人们来创造电视节目的想法时，我们会从市场感知、对人们会购买什么的感知中获得许多各种形式的艺术。我不知道这是否是这些事情之一——通过民意调查以这种方式创作艺术，你可以得到称职的艺术，但你不会得到任何真正鼓舞人心的东西，任何真正抓住你心的东西。
You talk in cliches. I'm sorry. But it's the other cliche, you know. We have a cliche of polls and a cliche of heart. In one, of course, it's polling people, asking them constantly, and we don't believe that art can be produced this way, really. Good art, let's say. But on the other hand, we have this image of this crazy artist with a lot of hair, torturing canvas, whatever. As cliche, as utopian, let's say, as the first idea. So you prefer this cliche to the other cliche.
你说的是陈词滥调。我很抱歉。但这是另一种陈词滥调，你知道。我们有关于民意调查的陈词滥调和关于心的陈词滥调。当然，在其中一个中，它是民意调查人们，不断询问他们，而我们不相信艺术可以以这种方式产生，真的。好艺术，我们这样说吧。但另一方面，我们有这个疯狂艺术家的形象，头发很多，折磨画布，不管是什么。像第一个想法一样陈词滥调，像乌托邦。所以你更喜欢这种陈词滥调而不是另一种。
In 1996, Melamid and Komar expanded the work. Teaming up with a musician named Dave Soldier, they surveyed music audiences. Favorite length of song? 60% of respondents said 3 to 10 minutes. Favorite topic for a song? 36% said a story, 32% said love. Most hated topic for a song? 33% said holidays, 10% said religion.
1996年，梅拉米德和科马尔扩展了这项工作。与一位名叫戴夫·索尔杰的音乐家合作，他们调查了音乐观众。最喜欢的歌曲长度？60%的受访者说是3到10分钟。最喜欢的歌曲主题？36%的人说是故事，32%的人说是爱。最讨厌的歌曲主题？33%的人说是节日，10%的人说是宗教。
Soldier took the data and produced two songs, one with all the things that people said they most hate in a song-- that is 21 minutes long, that song-- and one with all the qualities that respondents said they wanted most in a song. Dave Soldier joined us in the studio.
索尔杰获取了数据并制作了两首歌，一首包含了人们说他们在歌曲中最讨厌的所有东西——那首歌有21分钟长——另一首包含了受访者说他们在歌曲中最想要的所有品质。戴夫·索尔杰和我们一起在工作室里。
American popular music is almost what people want to hear in the most popular song. If you ask people, what are your favorite instruments, and add up the seven or eight favorite instruments, they are those that are used in conventional radio top-40-type pop music-- guitar, piano, bass drums, synthesizer.
美国流行音乐几乎是人们想在最受欢迎的歌曲中听到什么。如果你问人们，你们最喜欢的乐器是什么，并加起来七八种最喜欢的乐器，它们就是那些在传统电台前40名流行音乐中使用的乐器——吉他、钢琴、低音鼓、合成器。
Let's play a little bit of this so people can hear a little bit.
让我们播放一点这个，这样人们可以听一点。
[MUSIC -- MOST WANTED SONG]
[音乐 -- 最受欢迎的歌曲]
Yeah, I mean, that sounds just like any pop song that could be on the radio.
是的，我是说，那听起来就像电台里可能播放的任何流行歌曲。
Well, that's pretty much, apparently, what people wanted. The favorite vocal styles are low male and low female, rock/R&B.
嗯，那很显然就是人们想要的。最喜欢的声乐风格是低沉男性和低沉女性，摇滚/R&B。
Low male, low female?
低沉男性，低沉女性？
Yeah. They like low female voices more than they like high female voices. In fact, the high female voice is the second-least-preferred voice. The least-preferred voices of all are kid's voices.
是的。他们喜欢低沉的女性声音多于高亢的女性声音。事实上，高亢的女性声音是第二不受欢迎的声音。所有人中最不受欢迎的声音是小孩的声音。
[MUSIC -- MOST WANTED SONG]
[音乐 -- 最受欢迎的歌曲]
Dave, can I ask you to talk about the least-popular song? What did people hate the most, and what did you have to fit into this song?
戴夫，我可以请你谈谈最不受欢迎的歌曲吗？人们最讨厌什么，你必须把什么塞进这首歌里？
There was quite a diversity in hatred. There were a lot of hated instruments. They're all personal favorites of mine, of course. The bagpipe, the accordion, the harp, the organ, the banjo, the tuba, for instance. We had to make sure that all of those were in there.
在厌恶方面有相当多的多样性。有很多受人讨厌的乐器。当然，它们都是我个人的最爱。风笛、手风琴、竖琴、风琴、班卓琴、大号，举例来说。我们必须确保所有这些都在里面。
And when it comes to most unwanted vocal styles, you found opera and rap were the two most unwanted vocal styles. And so what you did is that, in this song that you put together, you have an opera singer rapping.
当谈到最不受欢迎的声乐风格时，你发现歌剧和说唱是两种最不受欢迎的声乐风格。所以你所做的是，在你拼凑的这首歌里，你让一位歌剧歌手在说唱。
[MUSIC -- LEAST WANTED SONG]
[音乐 -- 最不受欢迎的歌曲]
You see, if only 10% of people like opera and only 10% of people like rap, and say these two categories don't overlap very well, that means that if you put both of them in there, only 1% of people will be left who can still listen to the piece. So we put everything in there that people don't like. For instance, some people detest cowboy music. So we have the opera singer singing rap about cowboys.
你看，如果只有10%的人喜欢歌剧，只有10%的人喜欢说唱，并且假设这两个类别重叠得不是很好，这意味着如果你把两者都放进去，只会剩下1%的人还可以听这首作品。所以我们把人们不喜欢的东西都放进去了。比如，有些人憎恨牛仔音乐。所以我们有这位歌剧歌手唱着关于牛仔的说唱。
[MUSIC -- LEAST WANTED SONG]
[音乐 -- 最不受欢迎的歌曲]
People tend to like moderate tempos-- that is, the speed of the music, how fast it sounds. So we're sure that we're going to have something that people really dislike if it, say, features a bagpipe, an opera singer singing about cowboys, and a children's choir sung very, very slowly.
人们倾向于喜欢适中的节奏——也就是音乐的速度，它听起来有多快。所以我们确信，如果它，比如说，以风笛、唱着关于牛仔的歌剧歌手和唱得非常、非常缓慢的儿童合唱团为特色，我们肯定会得到一些人们非常不喜欢的东西。
[MUSIC -- LEAST WANTED SONG]
[音乐 -- 最不受欢迎的歌曲]
Can I ask the two of you-- can you listen to either of these songs in your own home?
我可以问你们两个——你们能在自己家里听这两首歌中的任何一首吗？
Well, actually I've grown to love both of them. I feel kind of guilty.
嗯，事实上我已经开始喜欢这两首歌了。我感到有点内疚。
You know, I got a lot of people who said they really love this music.
你知道，我有很多说他们真的很喜欢这音乐的人。
And musicians, in particular, will call me and say, I just heard the new record. I fell asleep during the most favorite and I loved the least favorite.
特别是音乐家，会打电话给我说，我刚刚听了那张新唱片。我在听最喜欢的那首时睡着了，而我爱上了最不受欢迎的那首。
Yeah, I kind of  love the least favorite too. Why do you think we're all going for the least favorite?
是的，我也算爱上了最不受欢迎的那首。你认为为什么我们都倾向于最不受欢迎的那首？
Because it's a minority. The least favorite is the least favorite. It's not hated music. It's just a small percentage of people [INTERPOSING VOICES]
因为它是少数派。最不受欢迎的那首就是最不受欢迎的。它不是被憎恨的音乐。它只是很小比例的人[交谈声]
I guess the obvious thing is we like to think of ourselves as being in this elite category.
我想显而易见的事情是我们喜欢认为自己属于这个精英类别。
That is not why we like that song. We don't like because we think of ourselves as being-- we don't like the children's choir coming in because we thinks of ourselves as a cultural elite.
那不是我们喜欢那首歌的原因。我们不喜欢并不是因为我们认为自己属于——我们不喜欢儿童合唱团进来并不是因为我们认为自己是文化精英。
Because it's done by the poll and polls are always right.
因为它是民意调查做出来的，而民意调查总是正确的。
That is not why we love it.
那不是我们爱它的原因。
[MUSIC -- LEAST WANTED SONG]
[音乐 -- 最不受欢迎的歌曲]
Here's the whole thing, Alex and Dave, is that in your attempt to just go straight by the numbers, what you've done is you've accidentally ended up with the lonely genius creating a real work of art. You've actually stumbled into the other model.
这是整件事，亚历克斯和戴夫，就是当你们试图完全按照数字走时，你们意外地以孤独的天才创作了一部真正的艺术作品而告终。你们实际上偶然进入了另一种模型。
I think I'd argue that with you.
我想我会为此与你争论。
Alex?
亚历克斯？
Accidentally maybe. No accidentally, not accidentally, incidentally, but we get it.
偶然也许。不偶然，不是偶然，是附带的，但我们得到了它。
But then we owe our genius to the people, just like all geniuses. We're finding what's in our culture and channeling the people's will.
但随后我们把我们的天才归功于人民，就像所有天才一样。我们正在寻找我们文化中有什么，并引导人民的意志。
[MUSIC -- LEAST WANTED SONG]
[音乐 -- 最不受欢迎的歌曲]
Do you think that there are some things that should just stay unquantified, some things we should not try to put into numbers?
你认为有些事情应该保持未量化吗，有些事情我们不应该尝试用数字去衡量？
You know, we have to have a criteria at any expense. If numbers, let it be numbers. But we need to know. We need to have a conviction. We need to have a common belief among all of us, a common faith. And right now, the common faith is in numbers, and let it be this way.
你知道，我们必须不惜一切代价有标准。如果数字，那就让它成为数字。但我们需要知道。我们需要有信念。我们需要在我们所有人之间有一个共同的信仰，一个共同的信念。而现在，共同的信念是在数字中，那就让它这样吧。
Because it's better than nothing.
因为它比什么都没有要好。
It's much better than nothing.
它比什么都没有要好得多。
[MUSIC -- LEAST WANTED SONG]
[音乐 -- 最不受欢迎的歌曲]
Act Three, When Days are Numbered. By describing some things in numbers, in data, it usually means that there are other things that we are choosing not to quantify and not to look at at all. Adam Davidson is an economics correspondent for NPR. He co-reports some of the economic coverage we do here on our show, and does the Planet Money podcast. But years ago, he did a story for us about his uncle Jerry. His uncle Jerry spends a lot of time gathering data and putting it into lists-- a list of sports scores going back decades, a list of all the people he has ever telephoned, a list of all the sales at the pharmacy he works at since he began working there. A list of all the lists. And then one list, the list that he values more than any other list, the list documenting his daily life. Here's Adam.
第三幕，当日子屈指可数时。通过用数字、数据描述某些事物，通常意味着还有其他事物是我们选择不去量化、根本不去看的。亚当·戴维森是NPR的一位经济通讯记者。他是我们节目中一些经济报道的共同报道员，并制作了《星球货币》播客。但多年前，他为我们做了一个关于他叔叔杰瑞的故事。他的叔叔杰瑞花了很多时间收集数据并把它们放入清单中——一份追溯几十年的体育比分清单，一份他打过电话的所有人的清单，一份他自开始工作以来在药房工作的所有销售记录清单。清单的清单。然后是一份清单，他比任何其他清单都更珍视的清单，记录他日常生活的清单。这是亚当。
My uncle Jerry's lists are something I've heard about my whole life, and I finally decided to find out what they're all about and to get to know him better. Jerry's always been quiet. He lives alone right near where he grew up, my dad's baby brother, in Worcester, Massachusetts. He's 52. He gets a monthly SSI check and he has a two-day-a-week job at a big CVS pharmacy. He told me that he's written down everything he's done, every day, since 1955 when he was 10 years old.
我叔叔杰瑞的这些清单是我一生中一直听说的，我终于决定找出它们到底是怎么回事，并更好地了解他。杰瑞一直都很安静。他住在离他长大的地方很近的地方，我父亲最小的弟弟，在马萨诸塞州伍斯特市。他52岁。他领取每月一次的补充保障收入支票，并且在一家大型CVS药房有一份每周两天的兼职工作。他告诉我，自1955年他10岁起，他写下了他每天做的每一件事。
My brother Jack told me Sunday, he said, remember, I told you years ago them lists were going to be worth nothing? I told him a thing. I said, look, I don't know what this is going to come to, but something's going to come out of this. I have this funny feeling.
我哥哥杰克星期天告诉我，他说，还记得吗，我几年前告诉过你那些清单什么用都没有？我对他说了件事。我说，看，我不知道这会变成什么样，但会有什么东西从中产生。我有这种奇怪的感觉。
And what do you think that is?
你觉得那是什么？
I don't know. It looks something good. It's going to make me happy. I know that. It's going to make me very, very, very happy. I know that.
我不知道。看起来像是好事。它会让我开心。我知道这一点。它会让我非常、非常、非常开心。我知道这一点。
Jerry always carries a scrap of paper in his shirt pocket or in his wallet, and he writes down everywhere he goes and everyone he talks to on the phone over the course of the day. At the end of the day, he takes everything he's written on the scrap paper and copies it onto one of those desk calendars where each day has its own page and the whole year sits on a little plastic stand with two narrow metal rings in the middle. He checks and re-checks every item. Only when he knows everything was copied properly does he put a check or an OK at the bottom of the desk calendar page. Once he's done that, right before he goes to sleep, that day is complete.
杰瑞总是随身带着一张废纸放在衬衫口袋或钱包里，他写下他去过的每一个地方以及他在一天中通过电话交谈过的每一个人。一天结束时，他把他写在废纸上的一切拿出来，抄写到那种每一天都有自己页面的台历上，整整一年坐在一个带有两个窄金属环在中间的小塑料架子上。他核对并重新核对每一个项目。只有当他知道一切都正确抄写时，他才在台历页面的底部打一个勾或一个OK。一旦他这样做了，就在他睡觉前，那一天就完整了。
This is yesterday.
这是昨天。
That's sitting on the TV?
那是坐在电视机上的？
Yes, sitting on my television. That's what I did all day yesterday.
是的，坐在我的电视机上。那就是我昨天整天做的事。
Wow, that's a long day.
哇，那可是漫长的一天。
Yeah, it sure was. Saturday, December 13, 1997. Sunny and cold. Honey Farms checked twice. Marie call Jerry and Sheryl twice. Check once. Cambridge eye doctors, check. Walgreens, Lincoln Street--
是的，确实如此。星期六，1997年12月13日。阳光明媚且寒冷。Honey Farms核对了两次。玛丽给杰瑞和谢丽尔打了两次电话。核对一次。剑桥眼科医生，核对。沃尔格林，林肯街——
The check marks indicate how many times he's done something. Every event gets at least one check, so if he goes to the store five times, that's five checks. Every event gets its own line, and each day's list is about eight or nine lines long. One of the strange things about the list is that he always refers to himself in the third person. He writes Jerry, or his initials, JD. The words I or me never appear anywhere in these diaries. And he's got this elaborate code.
勾选标记表示他做了某件事多少次。每一个事件至少有一个勾，所以如果他去商店五次，那就是五个勾。每一个事件都有自己的行，每一天的清单大约有八或九行长。清单奇怪的事情之一是他总是用第三人称指代自己。他写杰瑞，或他的首字母JD。词语“我”或“我”从来没有出现在这些日记的任何地方。而且他有这种复杂的代码。
See, I put a star on the top of the thing. That means I had a great day. Plus I write in different color pens. Sometimes I write in black, and sometimes I write in blue. Blue means I'm very happy. Red means a semi-good day. Black means it's a bad day. Not a very bad day, but just a bad day.
看，我在东西顶部放了一颗星。那意味着我度过了美好的一天。加上我用不同颜色的笔写。有时我用黑色写，有时我用蓝色写。蓝色意味着我非常开心。红色意味着半好的一天。黑色意味着这是一个糟糕的一天。不是非常糟糕的一天，只是一个糟糕的一天。
In the pages we looked at, some days would have two or three blue items and the rest would be black. Other days, everything in the morning was black, while the afternoon was better-- it had the red and the blue. The thing is, even after he explained all of these codes and pen colors, I couldn't understand the diaries at all. No one could except for Jerry. He uses his own abbreviations.
在我们查看的页面中，有些天会有两三个蓝色的项目，其余的会是黑色的。其他天，早上的所有东西都是黑色的，而下午更好——它有红色和蓝色。问题是，即使在他解释了所有这些代码和笔颜色之后，我根本无法理解这些日记。除了杰瑞，没有人能理解。他使用他自己的缩写。
See, it says HFPLOT. I went to Honey Farms, Pleasant. And I was in the lot. PAS. That's Phyllis Ashland's sister's house. Let's see. S means sex. Or S-X, I put sometimes. [PHONE RINGS] Hello? Hey. Doing what?
看，它写着HFPLOT。我去了Honey Farms，Pleasant。而且我在地块里。PAS。那是菲利斯·阿什兰姐妹的房子。让我们看看。S意味着性。或者S-X，我有时会写。[电话铃响] 喂？嘿。在做什么？
Jerry's girlfriend Sheryl called and they talked for a long time.
杰瑞的女友谢丽尔打了电话，他们谈了很长时间。
Did you sleep good last night? Lucky you. I didn't sleep at all. Nope, getting very lonely. Do you care? I'm just kidding with you. Are we going to be hanging together tonight? I want to be with you, stupid. Jesus. The only thing I want to be. All right. Yes, dear. Bye. Sheryl, Sheryl, Sheryl, Sheryl.
昨晚睡得好吗？你真幸运。我根本没睡。不，变得非常孤独。你在乎吗？我在跟你开玩笑。我们今晚要在一起吗？我想和你在一起，傻瓜。天哪。我唯一想成为的。好的。是的，亲爱的。再见。谢丽尔，谢丽尔，谢丽尔，谢丽尔。
What are you doing now?
你现在在做什么？
I just put another check. That's two checks for her.
我刚刚又加了一个勾。那是给她的两个勾。
See, that to me is so funny, that you just had this really emotional conversation with her and all you did was put another check next to her name.
看，那对我来说太有趣了，你刚刚和她进行了这次真正情绪化的对话，而你所做的只是在她的名字旁边又加了一个勾。
Yeah, because I keep it all in here, what she says to me.
是的，因为我把她对我说的所有话都保存在这里面。
Jerry said he doesn't like to write about his feelings. That's why he just put a check. He doesn't want to write how he felt about talking to Sheryl or anyone else. He said it's nobody's business. Of course, that's the most interesting part. That's exactly what I wanted to know. Why was one phone call from Cheryl written in black, while another was in blue, and what happened that one day a McDonald's that made him put it down in red?
杰瑞说他不喜欢写他的感受。这就是为什么他只是加了一个勾。他不想写他对于和谢丽尔或其他任何人交谈的感觉。他说这是没人的事。当然，那是这一部分最有趣的地方。那正是我想知道的。为什么谢丽尔的一个电话被写成黑色，而另一个被写成蓝色，那一天在麦当劳发生了什么让他用红色记下？
My family doesn't understand Jerry's lists. We tease him about them. At Thanksgiving, Jerry had this big box with hundreds of pens, blue, black, red. My dad said, Jerry, why not just keep a few of them and throw the rest away. Jerry got angry. he said he'd saved those pens his whole life, and he needed them for his list.
我的家人不理解杰瑞的这些清单。我们取笑他。在感恩节，杰瑞有一个大盒子，里面有几百支笔，蓝色、黑色、红色。我父亲说，杰瑞，为什么不只留几支，把剩下的扔掉。杰瑞生气了。他说他一生都在存那些笔，他需要它们来记录清单。
It's like a hobby, but everybody says it's stupid. But I don't think it's stupid.
这就像一种爱好，但每个人都说它很傻。但我不认为它傻。
How did you start doing these lists? Do you remember when you started?
你是怎么开始做这些清单的？你记得你是什么时候开始的吗？
I don't know why. I don't know. My father maybe got me into it, because he used to write down things too, when he had appointments.
我不知道为什么。我不知道。也许是我父亲让我进入这个习惯的，因为他在有预约时也过去记录东西。
And he doesn't like you doing lists.
而且他不赞成你做清单。
He thinks it's a waste of time. He says, why do you write down everything? And I said, well, I just like to. You write down appointments when you have business meetings, don't you? He said, yeah, but I'm a businessman. You're not. [PHONE RINGS] Can you pause that for a second?
他认为这浪费时间。他说，你为什么要把所有东西都写下来？我说，好吧，我只是喜欢。你在有商务会议时也会记录预约，不是吗？他说，是的，但我是个商人。你不是。[电话铃响] 你能暂停一下吗？
It was Sheryl again. When Jerry hung up, he took out his scrap paper and put another check next to her name.
又是谢丽尔。当杰瑞挂断电话时，他拿出他的废纸，在她的名字旁边又加了一个勾。
When we were talking, Jerry said to me, I hate the past. But in fact he's surrounded himself with the past. When you walk in his apartment, it's crammed with stuff. There are piles of newspapers all over the place that he uses to keep track of his sports scores, dozens of boxes of papers, old clothes, his children's toys from the '70s, store receipts from years ago, memos from jobs he's long since left. He keeps the answering machine cassettes with every message he's ever gotten. His history is around him all the time.
当我们在通话时，杰瑞对我说，我讨厌过去。但事实上，他把自己包围在过去之中。当你走进他的公寓时，里面塞满了东西。到处都是报纸堆，他用它们来跟踪他的体育比分，几十个纸箱，旧衣服，他孩子70年代的玩具，几年前的商店收据，他很久以前离开的工作的备忘录。他保存着带有他收到的每条消息的应答机磁带。他的历史始终在他周围。
I don't think anybody else could survive what I went through a lot. Divorces, losing my kids, two marriages. I thought that was the end of my world when I finally got divorced. That is hard. I think that is worse than a death to go through. It is. It is hard. You never went through it, but it's hard. It's hard.
我不认为还有谁能在我也经历过很多的事情中幸存下来。离婚，失去我的孩子，两次婚姻。当我最终离婚时，我以为那是我的世界末日。那很难。我认为那比经历死亡更糟糕。是的。它很难。你从来没有经历过，但它很难。它很难。
It's just a weird thing when you go to court for a divorce. The wife says everything of what she says. Then she leaves the room. Then you say everything that you want to say. And the judge called both of us back and he says, granted. But I had nobody there to fall back onto when I get divorced. That really bothered me today. The day I got divorced in my two divorces, I just had nobody there for me. I just came home and slept.
当你去法庭离婚时，这真是一件奇怪的事情。妻子说她说的所有话。然后她离开房间。然后你说你想说的所有话。法官把我们两个都叫回去，他说，准许。但在我离婚时，我没有人可以依靠。这今天真的困扰着我。在我两次离婚的那天，我身边真的没有人。我只是回到家，睡着了。
On the phone, you were saying that you've wanted to tell your father-- you said, I could have been somebody because of these lists. What did you mean by that?
在电话里，你说你想告诉你的父亲——你说，因为这些清单我本可以成为某个人。你那是什么意思？
My life story. Mostly my life story is what I did. It's like the diary of Anne Frank. Mine would be the diary of Jerry.
我的生活故事。大部分我的生活故事是我做了什么。它就像《安妮日记》。我的将是杰瑞日记。
Why do you think people like reading the diary of Anne Frank?
你认为为什么人们喜欢阅读《安妮日记》？
Well, it's interesting, because she wrote different things about what she did in her life and all that. It'd be just like my story. But I think mine would be the best-seller, because I had more interesting things to do with my life. I went to the zoo, to California, everything. England, I went to England. I went everywhere. I came a long way, really. I came a long way. And I'm just a survivor. Your father used to say, that's all I am. A survivor. I live by myself. Let's see, what is it? 19 years already. Didn't have a wife or nothing, for 19 years. I survive out there anyway.
嗯，这很有趣，因为她写了关于她生活中所做不同事情以及所有那些东西。它会就像我的故事。但我认为我的会是畅销书，因为我一生中有更有趣的事情要做。我去了动物园，去了加利福尼亚，一切。英格兰，我去了英格兰。我到处都去了。我真的走了很长一段路。我走了很长一段路。而我只是一个幸存者。你父亲过去常说，那就是我所是的一切。一个幸存者。我独自生活。让我们看看，这是什么？已经19年了。没有妻子或任何东西，19年了。我反正是在外面幸存下来了。
I don't think Jerry would put it this way, but when I look at his lists, I think he does them because they give him something to do every day. And then seeing every day written down like that, page after page in perfect order, his life seems less empty, less lonely. The lists prove he's spent time with people who care about him, and he's been places, and he's done things.
我不认为杰瑞会这样说，但当我看着他的这些清单时，我认为他做它们是因为它们给了他每天可以做的事情。然后看着每一天像那样被写下来，一页又一页地完美有序，他的生活似乎不那么空虚，不那么孤独。这些清单证明了他和在乎他的人在一起，他去过地方，他做过事情。
Holy mackerel. It's like a blizzard. Can you believe that? It's snowing like heck down here. I don't believe this. See, I have to write that down in the book, say it snowed. That's amazing.
天哪。就像一场暴风雪。你能相信吗？这里在下大雪。我不相信这个。看，我必须把那个记在书里，说下雪了。那太神奇了。
Coming up, applying numbers to love with incredible success. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，应用数字于爱情并获得惊人的成功。那是在一分钟后，来自国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, and invite a variety of writers and performers and reporters to take a whack at that theme. Today's program, using numbers where they should not be used. We've arrived at Act Four of our program, The Salesman. Will Powers works for a marketing firm called Brand Solutions in Seattle. And his boss wanted everybody in the firm to understand better the principles of brand loyalty and how to achieve it. And so the boss had Will and the other staffers do this exercise where they had to market themselves to someone they knew, using all the tools of modern brand marketing. Will chose his wife.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，并邀请各种作家、表演者和记者来尝试这个主题。今天的节目，在不应该使用数字的地方使用数字。我们已经到达了我们节目的第四幕，推销员。威尔·鲍尔斯在西雅图一家名为品牌解决方案的营销公司工作。他的老板希望公司里的每个人都能更好地理解品牌忠诚度的原则以及如何实现它。所以老板让威尔和其他员工做了这个练习，他们必须利用现代品牌营销的所有工具向他们认识的人推销自己。威尔选择了他的妻子。
You know, really, why not my wife? She's probably the closest person to me, and I think, as you'll see later on, as I discuss, it was a great opportunity to learn a little bit more about that customer.
你知道，真的，为什么不是我妻子？她可能是与我最亲近的人，而且我认为，正如你稍后会看到的，正如我所讨论的，这是一个了解那个客户多一点点的好机会。
It's so strange to hear you say that word
听到你说那个词真奇怪。
I know. It is funny. But it's really interesting-- obviously, I don't think of my wife as a customer. I dated my wife since we were 15, and we went to the same college, and we got married right after college, and we've been married for five years. And when I went home to do this exercise with her, I was like, oh, there's nothing she's going to tell me that I don't know. I know her inside and out.
我知道。这很有趣。但这真的很有趣——显然，我不认为我的妻子是客户。我从15岁起就和我的妻子约会，我们上了同一所大学，我们在大学毕业后就结婚了，我们结婚五年了。当我回家和她一起做这个练习时，我当时想，哦，没有什么她会告诉我不我不了解的。我了解她的里里外外。
All right, well, let's talk about the process you went through.
好的，好吧，让我们谈谈你经历的过程。
I had my wife come up with her attributes and what's important to her within the product.
我让我妻子想出了她的属性以及在产品中对她来说重要的是什么。
This is what she's looking for in her husband.
这就是她寻找丈夫时想要的。
Exactly. She came up with honest, funny, forgiving, patient, understanding, strong, protective, empathetic, loving, and gentle. And really, to take it the next step further, I said, well, these are really great attributes, but tell me how I can act upon these. How can I, the organization providing the service, please you? And it's really saying, where can I find ways to better provide the service to you?
正是如此。她提出了诚实、风趣、宽容、耐心、理解、强大、保护性、善解人意、充满爱心和温柔。而且真的，为了更进一步，我说，嗯，这些确实是很好的属性，但告诉我我该如何根据这些采取行动。作为提供服务的组织，我该如何取悦你？这真的是在说，我在哪里可以找到方法更好地为你提供这项服务？
Now, if you actually working with a real firm that was really selling a product, this would be more or less the equivalent of focus-grouping the customers.
现在，如果你实际上是在与一家真正销售产品的真实公司合作，这将或多或少相当于对客户进行焦点小组研究。
Exactly. Exactly.
正是如此。正是如此。
You'd get a bunch of customers. You'd get them into a room. You'd focus-group them on what is it that they really want from the company.
你会找一群客户。你会把他们带到一个房间。你会对他们进行关于他们真正想从公司得到什么的焦点小组研究。
Exactly. That's exactly right. Me, being the product, how can I show you that I'm loving and gentle and understanding and empathetic, et cetera. What would be a way that I could follow through on these? So she actually gave me examples. You know, when you hold my hand, you make me laugh, to take time out of the day to make sure I'm happy and OK, hang up your clothes after a business trip, try to stay healthy, work hard, work for our future, work at our relationship, examples like that.
正是如此。那是完全正确的。我是产品，我该如何向你展示我是充满爱心、温柔、理解和善解人意等等的？有什么方法可以让我跟进这些？所以她实际上给了我例子。你知道，当你握住我的手，你让我笑，在一天中抽出时间确保我开心和OK，在商务旅行后挂好你的衣服，试着保持健康，努力工作，为我们的未来工作，为我们的关系工作，诸如此类的例子。
So what I said-- and this what we usually do in organizations. We do a brand ladder. An example would be, we work with some major restaurant chains. And they might list something like, it's clean. And that's a very functional attribute. Well, OK, if they're concentrating on that and it's clean, how does that make you feel? Well, that makes me feel comfortable at the restaurant. OK, when you're comfortable at the restaurant, how does that make you feel? Well, it makes me feel that I can forget my problems. Well, then when you forget your problems, how does that make you feel? Well, then I can concentrate on other aspects of my life, like my children. So we go from very small and functional, from clean, to concentrating on children and full fulfillment.
所以我说——这也是我们通常在组织中做的。我们做一个品牌阶梯。一个例子是，我们与一些主要的连锁餐厅合作。他们可能会列出像，它很干净这样的东西。这是一个非常功能性的属性。嗯，好的，如果他们专注于那个，而且它很干净，那让你感觉如何？嗯，这让我在餐厅感觉很舒服。好的，当你在餐厅感觉舒服时，那让你感觉如何？嗯，这让我感觉我可以忘记我的问题。嗯，那么当你忘记你的问题时，那让你感觉如何？嗯，那么我可以专注于我生活中的其他方面，比如我的孩子。所以我们从非常小和功能性，从干净，到专注于孩子和充分满足。
What I said is, if it works for an organization, once again, why couldn't it work for me selling my product? So after my wife listed her examples, I pulled one out, and I said, OK, Laura. Well, picking out my clothes, let's say, when I come home and I throw my garment bag on the bed and I'm supposed to hang up my clothes-- sometimes I don't. I just dump it out and usually I'm exhausted. But I said, let's just start with that. Let's say, if I pick up my clothes, what does that do for you? What is that going to give you?
我说的是，如果它对一个组织有效，再次，为什么它不能对我销售我的产品有效？所以在我妻子列出她的例子后，我拿出一个，我说，好的，劳拉。嗯，挑出我的衣服，我们这样说吧，当我回家时，我把我的服装袋扔在床上，而且我本应该挂好我的衣服——有时我没有。我只是把它倒出来，通常我已经精疲力竭了。但我说，让我们从那个开始吧。让我们说，如果我捡起我的衣服，那对你有什么作用？那会给你带来什么？
And she goes well, really, what that does for me is that confirms teamwork, that we're a partnership in this relationship. And I said, OK, that's great. And knowing that we're a team, how does that make you feel? Or what does that give you? And she goes, well, when I know I'm a team and you're helping me out and we're really working as a team together, that leads to a strong relationship.
她说嗯，真的，那对我来说作用是证实了团队合作，我们是这段关系中的伙伴关系。我说，好的，太棒了。而且知道我们是一个团队，那让你感觉如何？或者那给你带来了什么？她说，嗯，当我意识到我是一个团队，你正在帮助我，而且我们确实是在作为一个团队一起工作，那会导致一种强有力的关系。
It makes her feel like she has a strong relationship.
这让她感觉她拥有强有力的关系。
Yeah, exactly, in that she can rely on me. And I said, well, that's fantastic. What do you when you have a strong relationship? How does that make you feel? And she goes, well, that is total love and total reassurance. And I said, wow, that's really great. So I went from something very simple, as picking up clothes from my garment bag when I come home from a business trip, very functional, to total love and strength.
是的，正是如此，在这个意义上她可以依靠我。我说，嗯，那太棒了。当你拥有强有力的关系时你会做什么？那让你感觉如何？她说，嗯，那是完全的爱和完全的保证。我说，哇，那真的很棒。所以我从非常简单的事情，比如我从商务旅行回家时从我的服装袋里捡起衣服，非常功能性，变成了完全的爱和力量。
And another example was calling me. And I'm usually pretty good about that when I travel, or even when I'm at work, calling her.
另一个例子是给我打电话。当我旅行时，或者甚至当我在工作时，我通常做得很好，给她打电话。
You used to call her during the day, during the work day?
你过去在白天，在工作日给她打电话？
Yeah, just to see how she's doing and stuff. And maybe some days I would forget or I'd be busy. But now I make it a point, because obviously she's a customer and she's viewing my product-- that's important to her. And as a customer, I know I'm going to satisfy her that way. The same with coming home and hanging up the garment bag and the clothes within it.
是的，只是看看她怎么样之类的事情。也许有些天我会忘记或者我会很忙。但现在我把它作为一个重点，因为显然她是客户，而且她正在审视我的产品——这对她很重要。而且作为一个客户，我知道我会以那种方式满足她。回家并挂起服装袋和里面的衣服也是一样。
You know what really strikes me as you talk about this, one of the things about it that I think is interesting, is it makes you really think about how often do any of us go to the people in our lives and ask, are you getting from me what you want?
你知道当你谈论这个时真正打动我的是，我认为其中一件有趣的事情是，这让你真正思考我们生命中有多少人去问我们生活中的人，你从我这里得到了你想要的吗？
Exactly. And really, in a nutshell, that's exactly what this accomplished. Are you satisfied with the product?
正是如此。而且真的，简而言之，这正是这个所实现的。你对这个产品满意吗？
Yeah. Before you actually went through this process with her, had she always-- she would say every now and then, you shouldn't leave your stuff, your garment bag, you shouldn't just leave it sitting around, I want you to pick it up. I mean, she had said this before?
是的。在你实际与她经历这个过程之前，她是否一直——她会时不时地说，你不应该留下你的东西，你的服装袋，你不应该只是把它放在周围，我想要你捡起它。我是说，她以前说过这个吗？
Yeah. Obviously, these aren't really big earth-shattering--
是的。显然，这些并不是真正重大的、惊天动地的——
No, I know. But to me, that's the interesting thing. Why was it so different doing it in this context? Why is it in this context you got the message, whereas before you didn't?
不，我知道。但对我来说，这是有趣的事情。为什么在这个背景下做它如此不同？为什么在这个背景下你得到了信息，而以前你没有？
Well, I think in the past I've come home and it's always been just something kind of under the breath of, you know, I would appreciate if you would have called me, or something to that effect. And I'm like, oh, yeah, OK, next time I promise I'll try to remember. But I think the reason why this was so powerful is we actually sat down across from each other, and it was just us, totally focused on each other. There was no other distractions.
嗯，我认为在过去我回家时，这总是只是某种某种抱怨，你知道，我如果能让你给我打电话我会很感激，或者某种类似的意思。而我当时想，哦，是的，好的，下次我保证我会尽量记住。但我认为这个之所以如此强大的原因是，我们实际上坐在彼此对面，而且只有我们，完全专注于彼此。没有任何其他干扰。
And she actually wrote it down. This is what's important to me. It's almost very elementary, spelling it out.
而且她实际上把它写了下来。这是对我很重要的事情。它几乎是非常基础的，把它拼出来。
You know what it's almost like? There's the way that women talk about certain emotional issues and there's the way that men talk about certain emotional issues, and what you and your wife sort of invented was a guy's way to talk about stuff that women normally want to talk about.
你知道它几乎像什么吗？女性谈论某些情感问题的方式和男性谈论某些情感问题的方式，而你和你的妻子某种程度上发明的是一种男性谈论女性通常想要谈论的事情的方式。
Yeah. That's a good point.
是的。那是一个好点。
It's like she spoke to you in guy language.
就像她用男人的语言和你说话。
I guess so. Because of my understanding of the organizational identity model, and because I could put it in business terms-- maybe you're right. Maybe that's how I connected with it and the light bulb went on.
我想是吧。因为我对组织身份模型的理解，而且因为我可以把它用商业术语表达出来——也许你是对的。也许这就是我与它连接并且灯泡亮起来的方式。
It's funny, because I think there are certain things about our own lives that we are hesitant to quantify. Do you know what I mean? And what you've done essentially in this example is that you've really tried to quantify-- what could be more delicate than a person's relationship in a marriage.
这很有趣，因为我认为我们自己生活中有些事情是我们犹豫去量化的。你知道我的意思吗？而你在这个例子中本质上所做的是，你确实尝试去量化——有什么能比婚姻中一个人的关系更微妙。
Well, like I said, I wanted to do this with my wife, because my wife is the most important person in the world to me. And I place my wife above anything else. And she is the number-one customer in my organization. And I have to make sure that she's 100% satisfied and happy with the product.
嗯，正如我所说，我想和我妻子做这个，因为我的妻子是我世界上最重要的人。而且我把我的妻子放在任何其他事情之上。她是我的组织中的第一客户。而且我必须确保她对这个产品100%满意和开心。
[MUSIC -- "ANYWAY YOU WANT ME" BY ELVIS PRESLEY]
[音乐 -- 埃尔维斯·普雷斯利的《无论你想我怎么样》]
Act Five, Break It Down. We end our program today with this attempt to quantify what love is, a short story by Lydia Davis, read by Matt Malloy. A quick warning to listeners before we begin. This story mentions the existence of sex. Nothing very explicit, but the fact that it does exist.
第五幕，拆解。我们今天以这种试图量化什么是爱的尝试结束我们的节目，利迪亚·戴维斯的一个短篇故事，由马特·马洛伊朗读。在开始之前给听众一个小警告。这个故事提到了性。没有什么非常明确的，但确实存在的事实。
He's sitting there staring at a piece of paper in front of him. He's trying to break it down. He says, I'm breaking it all down. The ticket was $600. And after that there was more for the hotel and food and so on, for just 10 days. Say, $80 a day. No, more like $100 a day. And we made love, say, once a day. On the average, that's $100 a shot. And each time it lasted maybe two or three hours, so that would be anywhere from $33 to $50 an hour, which is expensive.
他坐在那里盯着他面前的一张纸。他试图把它拆解。他说，我正在把它全部拆解。那张票是600美元。在那之后还有更多用于酒店、食物等等，仅10天时间。说，一天80美元。不，更像一天100美元。我们做爱，说，一天一次。平均而言，那是一次100美元。而且每次持续也许两三个小时，所以那将是每小时33到50美元不等，这是很昂贵的。
Though, of course, that wasn't all that went on, because we were together almost all day long. And she would keep looking at me, and every time she looked at me, that was worth something. And she smiled at me, and didn't stop talking and singing. Something I said, she would sail into it, a snatch, for me. She would be gone from me a little ways, but smiling too, and tell me jokes. I loved it, but didn't exactly know what to do about it, just smiled back at her and felt slow next to her, just not quick enough.
虽然，当然，那并不是发生的全部，因为我们几乎整天都在一起。她会一直看着我，而她每一次看我，那都值得一些东西。她对我微笑，并没有停止说话和唱歌。我说的一些东西，她会航行进入它，一个抓取，为了我。她会从我身边离开一点点，但也在微笑，并讲笑话给我听。我爱它，但并不确切知道该怎么做，只是向她微笑并感到在她身边很慢，只是不够快。
So she talked and touched me on the shoulder and the arm. She kept touching and stayed close to me. You're with each other all day long, and it keeps happening, the touches and smiles. And it adds up. It builds up and you know where you'll be that night. You're talking and every now and then you think about it. No, you don't think, you just feel it as kind of a destination, what's coming up after you leave wherever you are all evening.
所以她谈话并触摸我的肩膀和手臂。她一直触摸并保持靠近我。你们整天在一起，而且它一直在发生，触摸和微笑。它加起来了。它积累起来，你知道你那天晚上会去哪里。你在说话，时不时你会想到它。不，你不思考，你只是把它当作一种目的地去感受它，在你离开你整晚所在的任何地方之后将要发生什么。
And you're happy about it, and you're planning it all. Not it your head, really. Somewhere inside your body, or all through your body. It's all mounting up and coming together so that when you get in bed, you can't help it. It's a real performance. I mean, it all pours out, but slowly. You go easy until you can't anymore, or you hold back the whole time. You hold back and touch the edges of everything. You edge around it till you have to plunge in and finish it off.
而且你对此感到开心，你正在规划这一切。不是在你的头脑里，真的。在你的身体内的某个地方，或者通过你的整个身体。这一切都在堆积并聚集在一起，以便当你上床时，你忍不住。这是一个真正的表演。我是说，它全部涌出，但很慢。你轻松进行直到你不能再进行，或者你一直退缩。你退缩并触摸每一件事的边缘。你绕着它边缘走直到你必须冲进去并完成它。
And when you're finished, you're too weak to stand. But after a while you have to go to the bathroom, and you stand. Your legs are trembling. You hold onto the door frames. There's a little light coming in through the window. You can see your way in and out, but you can't really see the bed.
当你完成时，你太虚弱而无法站立。但在一段时间后你必须去洗手间，然后你站起来。你的腿在颤抖。你抓住门框。有一点光从窗户进来。你可以看到你进出的路，但你无法真正看到床。
So it's really not $100 a shot, because it goes on all day, from the start when you wake up and feel her body next to you. You don't miss a thing, not a thing, of what's going on next to you. Her leg, her arm, her shoulder, her face, that good skin. I've felt other good skin, but this skin is just the edge of something else. And you're going to start going. I mean, no matter how much you crawl all over each other, it won't be enough. And when your hunger dies down a little bit, then you start to think about how much you love her, and then that starts you off again. And her face-- and you look over at her face, and you can't believe how you got there, and how lucky, and it's all still a surprise. And it never stops. I mean, even after it's over, it never stops being a surprise.
所以它真的不是一次100美元，因为它整天都在进行，从你醒来并感觉到她的身体在你身边的那一刻开始。你没有错过任何事情，没有任何事情，关于在你身边正在发生的事情。她的腿，她的手臂，她的肩膀，她的脸，那层美好的皮肤。我感受过其他美好的皮肤，但这层皮肤只是其他东西的边缘。而且你将开始进行。我是说，无论你们互相爬行多少次，那都不会足够。而当你的饥饿感稍微减弱时，然后你开始思考你有多爱她，然后那又开始让你行动。还有她的脸——你看着她的脸，你无法相信你是如何到达那里的，以及多么幸运，而且这一切仍然是一个惊喜。而且它从不停止。我是说，即使在它结束后，它从不停止成为惊喜。
It's more like you have a good 16 or 18 hours a day of this going on. Even when you're not with her, it's still going on. I mean, it's good to be away from her because it's going to be so good to get back to her, you know. It's still there in you. And you can't go off and look at some old street or some old painting without feeling it in your body, and a few things that happened the day before that don't mean much by themselves or wouldn't mean much if you weren't having this thing together. But you can't forget, and it's all inside of you all the time. So it's more like, say, 16 into $100 would be $6 an hour, which isn't too much.
它更像你有每天16或18小时的好时光正在进行。即使当你不在她身边时，它仍然在进行。我是说，离开她很好，因为回到她身边会很好，你知道。它仍然在那里，在你里面。而且你不能走开去看着某条旧街道或某幅旧画，而不感觉到它在你的身体里，以及前一天发生的一些事情，如果你们没有一起发生这种事情，它们本身意义不大或意义不大。但你无法忘记，而且它一直都在你的身体里。所以它更像，说，16除以100美元将是每小时6美元，这并不是太多。
And then it really keeps going on while you're asleep, even though you're probably dreaming about something else. A building, maybe. I don't know. I kept dreaming every night, almost, about this building, because I'd spend a lot of every morning in this old stone building. And when I closed my eyes, I would see these cool spaces and have this peace inside me. I would see the bricks of the floor and the stone arches and the space, the emptiness between, like a kind of dark frame around what I could see beyond, a garden. And this space was like stone too, because of the coolness of it and the gray shadow, that kind of luminous shade that was glowing in the light of the sun falling beyond the arches. And there's also this great height of the ceiling. All this was in my mind all the time though I didn't know it until I close my eyes.
而且当你在睡觉时它真的会一直进行，即使你可能在梦中梦见其他东西。一座建筑，也许。我不知道。我几乎每天晚上都在梦见这座建筑，因为我会在那座古老的石头建筑里花费每天的很大一部分时间。当我闭上眼睛时，我能看到这些凉爽的空间，并在我内心拥有这种和平。我会看到地面的砖块和石拱门和空间，中间的空虚，像一种黑暗的框架围绕着我能看到超越花园的东西。而这个空间也像石头一样，因为它的凉爽和灰色的阴影，那种在落在拱门之外的太阳光中发光的明亮阴影。而且天花板也有这种巨大的高度。所有这些一直在我的脑海中，尽管我不知道，直到我闭上眼睛。
I'm asleep, and I'm not dreaming about her, but she's lying next to me and I wake up enough times in the night to remember she's there and notice, say, once she was lying on her back but now she's curled around me. I look at her closed eyes. I want to kiss her eyelids. I want to feel that soft skin under my lips but I don't want to disturb her. I don't want to see her frown as though, in her sleep, she's forgotten who I am and feels that just something is bothering her. And so I just look at her and hold onto it all, these times when I'm watching over her sleep, and she's next to me and isn't away from me the way she will be later. I want to stay awake all night just to go on feeling that. But I can't. I fall asleep again, though I'm speaking lightly, still trying to hold onto it.
我睡着了，我没有在梦中梦见她，但她躺在我身边，我在夜里醒来足够多次去记住她在那里并注意到，说，曾经她躺在她的背上，但现在她卷缩在我身边。我看着她闭着的眼睛。我想吻她的眼睑。我想感受我嘴唇下那层柔软的皮肤，但我不想打扰她。我不希望看到她皱眉，好像在她的睡梦中，她忘记了我是谁并感觉到只是某种东西在困扰她。所以我只是看着她并抓住这一切，这些我守着她的睡眠的时间，而她在我不身边，而不是她以后会离开我的方式。我想彻夜不醒只为了继续感受那一切。但我不能。我再次睡着了，尽管我说话很轻，仍然试图抓住它。
But it isn't over when it ends. I mean, it goes on after it's all over. She's still inside you like a sweet liqueur. You're filled with her. Everything about her has kind of bled into you-- her voice, her smell, the way her body moves. It's all inside of you, at least for awhile after.
但当它结束时它并没有结束。我是说，在一切结束后它还在继续。她仍然在你里面，像一种甜甜的利口酒。你充满了她。关于她的一切某种程度上流进了你——她的声音，她的气味，她身体移动的方式。这一切都在你里面，至少在之后的一段时间里。
Then you begin to lose it, and I'm beginning to lose it. You're afraid of how weak you are, that you can't get her all back into you again, and now the whole thing is going to be out of your body, and it's more in your mind than in your body. The pictures come to you one by one, and you look at them. Some of them last longer than others.
然后你开始失去它，而我正开始失去它。你害怕你有多虚弱，你无法再次把她全部拿回你里面，而现在整件事将离开你的身体，而且它更多是在你的思想里而不是在你的身体里。图片一张一张地来到你身边，你看着它们。它们中的一些持续的时间比其他长。
You were together in this very white clean place, a coffee house, having breakfast together. And the place is so white that against it you can see her clearly, her blue eyes, her smile, the colors of clothes, even the print of the newspaper she's reading when she's not looking up at you. The light brown and red and gold of her hair when she's got her head down reading. The brown coffee, the brown rolls, all against the white table and those white plates and silver urns and silver knives and spoons, and against that quiet of the sleepy people in that room sitting alone at their tables with just chinking and clattering of spoons and cups and saucers. And some hushed voices, her voice now and then rising and falling.
你们在这个非常白色干净的地方在一起，一家咖啡馆，一起吃早餐。而那个地方太白了，对着它你可以清楚地看到她，她蓝色的眼睛，她的微笑，衣服的颜色，甚至她没看着你时正在读的报纸的印记。当她低下头读时，她头发的浅棕色和红色和金色。棕色的咖啡，棕色的面包卷，全部对着白色桌子和那些白色的盘子和银色的瓮和银色的刀和勺，并对着那个房间里困倦的人们独自坐在他们的桌子旁，只有勺子和杯子和碟子的叮当声和撞击声。还有一些压低的声音，她的声音时不时升起和下降。
The pictures come to you and you have to hope they won't lose their life too fast and dry up, though you know they will, and that you'll also forget some of what happened, because already you're turning up little things that you nearly forgot.
图片来到你身边，你必须希望它们不会失去生命太快并干涸，尽管你知道它们会，而且你也会忘记发生的一些事情，因为已经你正在翻找你几乎忘记的小东西。
We were in bed, and she asked me, do I seem fat to you? And I was surprised because she didn't seem too worry about herself at all in that way, and I guess I was reading into it that she did worry about herself, so I answered what I was thinking, and said stupidly that she had a very beautiful body, that her body was perfect. And I really meant it as an answer, but she said kind of sharply, that's not what I asked. And so I had to try to answer her again, exactly what she had asked.
我们在床上，她问我，我看起来胖吗？而我很惊讶因为她看起来一点也不担心自己在那个方面，而我想我解读出她确实担心自己，所以我回答了我正在思考的，并愚蠢地说她有一个非常美丽的身体，她的身体是完美的。而我真的把它当作一个答案，但她有点尖锐地说，那不是我问的。所以我必须尝试再次回答她，正是她所问的。
And once she lay over against me, late at night, and she started talking, her breath in my ear, and she just went on and on and talked faster and faster. She couldn't stop, and I loved it. I just felt that all that life in her was running into me too. I had so little life in me. Her life, her fire, was coming into me in that hot breath in my ear. And I just wanted her to go on talking forever right there next to me, and I would go on living like that. I would be able to go on living, but without her-- I don't know.
有一次她躺在我身上，深夜，她开始说话，她的呼吸在我耳朵里，她只是继续下去并说得越来越快。她无法停止，我爱它。我只是觉得她身上所有的生命力也流入了我。我身上生命力太少了。她的生命力，她的火，正在流入我，在那我耳朵里炽热的呼吸中。而我只是希望她永远在那里在我身边说下去，而我会继续那样活着。我会能够继续活着，但没有她——我不知道。
Then you forget some of it all. Maybe most of it all. Almost all of it, in the end. And you work hard at remembering everything now, so you won't ever forget. But you can kill it too, even by thinking about it too much, though you can't help but thinking about it nearly all the time. And then when the pictures start to go, you start asking some questions, just little questions that sit in your mind without any answers. Like, why did she leave the light on when you came to bed one night, but it was off the next, but she had it on the night after that, and she had it off the last night? Why? And all the questions, little questions that nag at you like that.
然后你忘记了这一切的一些。也许这一切的大部分。最后几乎全部。而你现在正在努力记住一切，这样你就永远不会忘记。但你甚至可以通过过多地思考它来杀死它，尽管你忍不住几乎一直在思考它。然后当图片开始消失时，你开始问一些问题，只是坐在你脑海中没有任何答案的小问题。比如，为什么有一天你上床时她让灯开着，但第二天它是关的，但她在接下来的一天晚上把它开了，而且她在最后一天晚上把它关了？为什么？还有所有的问题，困扰着你的小问题。
And finally the pictures go and these dry little questions just sit there without any answers. And you're left with this large heavy pain in you that you try to numb by reading. Or you try to ease it by getting out into public places where there'll be people around you. But no matter how good you are at pushing that pain away, just when you think you're going to be all right for a little while, that you're safe, you're holding it off with all your strength and you're staying in some bare little numb spot of ground, then suddenly it will all come back. You'll hear a noise. Maybe it's a cat crying, or a baby, something else like her cry. You hear it and make that connection in a part of you you have no control over, and that pain comes back so hard that you're afraid, afraid of how you're going to fall back into it again. And you wonder-- no you're terrified at how you're ever going to climb out of it.
最后图片消失了，这些干燥的小问题只是坐在那里没有任何答案。而你留下这种巨大的沉重的痛苦在你里面，你试图通过阅读来麻木它。或者你试图通过走到有很多人的公共场所来缓解它。但无论你有多擅长推开那种痛苦，就在你认为你将在一小会儿时间内没关系时，你是安全的，你正用你所有的力量坚持住它，而你正停留在某种裸露的小麻木的地面点上，然后突然它将全部回来。你会听到一种噪音。也许是一只猫在哭，或者一个婴儿，其他像她哭声的东西。你听到它并在你无法控制的你的一部分做出那种连接，而且那种痛苦回来得如此剧烈以至于你害怕，害怕你将如何再次坠入其中。而且你想知道——不你被它感到恐惧，你将如何攀爬出来。
So it's not every hour of the day while it's happening. It's really for hours and hours every day after that, for weeks, though less and less. So that you could work out a ratio if you wanted. Maybe after six weeks, you're only thinking about it an hour or so in the day altogether, a few minutes here and there spread over, or a few and minutes here and there and a half an hour before you go to sleep. Or sometimes it all comes back and you stay awake half the night.
所以当它发生时并不是一天中的每一小时。它在之后真的是每天数小时数小时，持续数周，尽管越来越少。所以如果你愿意的话，你可以算出一种比例。也许六周后，你一天中总共只有一小时左右的时间在思考它，这里那里分散的几分钟，或者这里那里几分钟以及你睡觉前半小时。或者有时它全部回来，你半夜睡不着。
So when you add up all that, you've only spent maybe $3 an hour on it.
所以当你加起来所有这些，你在这个上面只花了也许每小时3美元。
If you have to figure in the bad times too, I don't know. There weren't any bad times with her, though. Maybe there was one bad time, when I told her I loved her. I couldn't help it. This was the first time this had happened with her. Now I was half-falling in love with her, or maybe completely, if she'd let me. But she couldn't, or I couldn't completely, because it was all going to be so short, and other things too. And so I told her.
如果你也必须算进糟糕的时候，我不知道。虽然，与她没有糟糕的时候。也许有一次糟糕的时候，当我告诉她我爱她时。我忍不住。这是这种情况第一次与她一起发生。现在我正处于一半坠入爱河，或者如果她允许我，也许完全坠入爱河。但她不能，或者我不能完全，因为它都将如此短暂，还有其他东西。所以我告诉了她。
And I didn't know of any way to tell her first that she didn't have to feel that this was a burden, the fact that I loved her, or that she didn't have to feel the same about me or say the same back, that it was just that I had to tell her, that's all. Because it was bursting inside me, and saying it wouldn't even begin to take care of what I was feeling, really. I couldn't say anything of what I was feeling because there was so much. Words couldn't handle it and making love only made it worse, because then I wanted words badly but they were no good, no good at all.
而我不知道任何方式先告诉她她不需要感到这是一个负担，我爱她的事实，或者她不需要对我有同样的感觉或说回同样的东西，那只是我必须告诉她，仅此而已。因为她在里面涌动，而说它甚至不会开始处理我正在感受的东西，真的。我无法说出我正在感受的任何东西，因为那里太多了。言语无法处理它，而做爱只会让它变得更糟，因为那时我非常想要言语，但它们没有用，一点用都没有。
But I told her anyway. I was lying on top of her in her hands were up by her head and my hands were on hers and our fingers were locked, and there was a little light on her face from the window, but I couldn't see her. And I was afraid to say it, but I had to say it, because I wanted her to know. It was the last night. I had to tell her then or I'd never have another chance, and I just said, before you go to sleep-- I have to tell you before you go to sleep that I love you.
但我还是告诉了她。我躺在她身上，她的手在她的头旁边，我的手在她的手上，我们的手指锁在一起，而从窗户有一点光落在她的脸上，但我无法看清她。而且我很害怕说出它，但我必须说出它，因为我想要她知道。那是最后一天晚上。我必须在那时告诉她，否则我就永远不会再有其他机会，而我只是说，在你睡觉前——我必须在你睡觉前告诉你我爱你。
And immediately, right away after, she said, I love you too. And it sounded to me as if she didn't mean it, a little flat. But then it usually sounds flat when somebody says, I love you too, because they're just saying it back even if they do mean it. And the problem is that I'll never know if she meant it. Or maybe someday she'll tell me whether she meant it or not, but there's no way to know now. And I'm sorry I did that. It was a trap I didn't mean to put her in. And I can see it was a trap, because if she hadn't said anything at all, that would have hurt me too, you know, as though she were taking something from me and just accepting it and not giving anything back. So she really had to. Even if just to be kind, she had to say it. And I don't really know now if she meant it.
而且立即，在那之后马上，她说，我也爱你。而在我听起来好像她不是真心的，有点平淡。但当有人说我也爱你时，它通常听起来平淡，因为他们只是说回它，即使他们确实是真心的。而问题是，我永远不会知道她是否是真心的。或者也许有一天她会告诉我她是否是真心的，但现在没有办法知道。而我为我做了那个感到抱歉。这是一个我不打算把她放进去的陷阱。而且我能看出这是一个陷阱，因为如果她什么都没说，那也会伤害我，你知道，好像她在从我这里拿走东西而只是接受它并没有回馈任何东西。所以她确实必须。即使只是为了仁慈，她必须说它。而我真的现在不知道如果她是真心的。
Another bad time-- or it wasn't exactly bad but it wasn't easy either-- was when I had to leave. The time was coming, and I was beginning to tremble and feel empty, nothing in the middle of me, nothing inside, nothing to hold me up on my legs. And then it came. Everything was ready and I had to go. So it was just a kiss, a quick one, as though we were afraid of what might happen after a kiss. And she was almost wild then. And she reached up to a hook by the door and took an old shirt, a green and blue shirt from the hook and put it in my arms for me to take away. The soft cloth was full of her smell.
另一次糟糕的时候——或者它不是完全糟糕，但它也不容易——是当我必须离开时。时间快到了，我开始颤抖并感到空虚，我中间没有东西，里面没有东西，没有东西支撑我的腿。然后它来了。一切都准备好了，我必须走。所以那只是一个吻，一个快速的吻，好像我们害怕吻之后可能会发生什么。而她那时几乎是狂野的。而且她伸手去拿门边的一个钩子，从钩子上拿了一件旧衬衫，一件绿色和蓝色的衬衫，并把它放在我的怀里让我带走。柔软的布料上满是她的气味。
And then we stood there close together looking at this piece of paper she had in her hand. And I didn't lose any of it. I was holding it tight that last minute or two, because this was it. We'd come to the end of it. Things always change, so this was really it. Over.
然后我们站在那里靠近彼此看着她手里这张纸。而我没有失去它的一点。在那最后的一两分钟里我把它紧紧抓住，因为就是这个。我们已经到了它的终点。事情总是改变，所以这确实是它。结束。
Maybe it works out all right. Maybe you haven't lost for doing it. I don't know. No, really, I mean, sometimes when you think of it, you feel like a prince really. You feel just like a king. And other times you're afraid. You're afraid not all the time, but now and then, of what it's going to do  to you. It's hard to know what to do with it now.
也许它进展得没问题。也许你没有因为做了它而失去。我不知道。不，真的，我是说，有时当你想到它时，你感觉你真是一个王子。你感觉就像一个国王。而其他时候你很害怕。你不是一直很害怕，但时不时，关于它将对你做什么。现在很难知道怎么处理它。
Walking away I looked back once, and the door was still open. I could see her standing far back in the dark of the room. I could only really see her white face still looking out at me, and her white arms.
走开时我回头看了一次，门仍然开着。我能看到她站在房间的黑暗深处。我只能真正看到她白色的脸仍然看着我，还有她白色的手臂。
I guess you get to a point where you look at that pain as if it were there in front of you three feet away lying in a box, an open box in a window somewhere. It's hard and cold like a bar of metal. You just look at it there and say, all right. I'll take it. I'll buy it. That's what it is. Because you know all about it, before you even go into this thing. You know the pain is part of the whole thing. And it isn't that we can say afterwards the pleasure was greater than the pain, and that's why you'd do it again. That has nothing to do it. You can't measure it, because the pain comes after and it lasts longer. So the question really is, why doesn't the pain make you say, I won't do it again, when the pain is so bad that you have to say that, but you don't?
我想你到达了一个地步，你看着那种痛苦，好像它就在你面前三英尺外躺在一个盒子里，某个地方窗口的一个敞开的盒子。它坚硬且寒冷像一根金属棒。你只是看着它在那里并说，好的。我会拿着它。我会买它。那是什么。因为你完全了解它，在你进入这件事情之前。你知道痛苦是整个事情的一部分。而且并不是说我们事后可以说快乐比痛苦更大，那就是为什么你会再做一次。那与它无关。你无法衡量它，因为痛苦在之后到来而且它持续的时间更长。所以问题真的是，为什么痛苦没有让你说，我不会再做一次，当痛苦是如此剧烈以至于你必须说那个，但你没有？
So I'm just thinking about it. How you can go in with $600, more like $1,000, and how you can come out with an old shirt.
所以我只是在想它。你是怎么能带着600美元，更像1000美元进入，以及你怎么能带着一件旧衬衫出来。
"Break It Down," by Lydia Davis, from her book of stories called Break It Down, read for us by actor Matt Malloy. Her latest book is called Varieties of Disturbance .
《拆解》，利迪亚·戴维斯，来自她名为《拆解》的故事书，由演员马特·马洛伊为我们朗读。她的最新书名为《干扰的种类》。
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and me, with Alix Spiegel and Julie Snyder. Senior editor for this show, Paul Tough. Music help today from John Connors. Our production manager is Seth Lind. Production help from PJ Vote. [ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS] Today's program was first broadcast all the way back in 1998.
嗯，我们的节目今天由南希·厄普代克和我制作，还有阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和朱莉·斯奈德。这个节目的高级编辑，保罗·塔夫。今天音乐帮助来自约翰·康纳斯。我们的制作经理是赛斯·林德。制作帮助来自PJ·沃特。[致谢] 今天的节目最早是在1998年播放的。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who asks the This American Life staff this every single day.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ管理层对我们节目的监督来自托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他每天都问《美国生活》员工这个。
How can I, the organization providing the service, please you?
作为提供服务的组织，我该如何取悦你？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。